this is a relationship I assume
I get enough Brown women yelling at me
in my life like I said I am married so
you guys sit there you're gonna shut the
up for the rest of the night
[Applause]
look at this are you guys a couple also
that'd be cool if I was flanked by
lesbians oh that's sick too dude good
for you I bet being gay seems like a
Resort compared to this huh
you got kids yo
really
two girls God damn dude that sucks yeah
I do a three of this
what do you got on one needle she like
other knee
you're not doing it right
this is not my good side you didn't get
my good side how can I post this on
Instagram
[Applause]
Benadryl you gotta do something to shut
her the up my bed